how do you know if you were in a toxic romantic relationship
well one of the ways I found in run like Hell
Nadine Macaluso new book about trauma bonds
is going through the Pathological Lover Checklist
which kind of helps gear you to sort of
take an inventory of the behaviours of your romantic partner
and see whether they are toxic
or have some sort of pathological underlying reasons
so here's the checklist
how much of your partner do you see in the following behaviours
speaks disrespectfully about his former partners
is deceitful and you catch him in lies is disrespectful towards
belittles or insults you is dominating
wants to control your behavior and restrict whom you connect with
blames you for everything is possessive and unnecessarily jealous lacks remorse
guilt or compassion is intimidating or threatening
is superficially charming in public
and those are just a few
there's several more that you wanna check out in her new book
you can find it on TikTok Shop